foreign
[Music]
you know
I know you're tired
[Music]
so this is
foreign
[Music]
turning me
foreign
[Music]
all right
foreign
I hope you all enjoyed this one I'm not
gonna lie the thing that made it come
together for me was the song I just
absolutely loved that song so much
um so yeah it was this was really fun
for me uh I want to put out a quick
thank you to flow toys for sponsoring
this video and uh giving me a reason to
go out and get some my dance on here
um if you'd like to grab a set of those
pod POI with FPC tethers that I was
using in this video you can do so by
heading on over to flowtoys.com and
using my special promo code drexfactor
2023 with a zero instead of an O at
checkout that will get you a discount on
your order and even better it helps out
the channel so go check that out please
and thank you and thank you once again
to flow toys for sponsoring this video
and speaking of thank yous I owe a big
thank you to the Friends of the channel
big thanks too dark monk fire Mecca flow
fests flow toys juggling calling
pyroterra light toys spin balls and
Ultra POI for helping to make the videos
on this channel possible you can learn
more about all these awesome companies
and the work that they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links that I have down
in the description of this video and
special thanks to the non-business
Friends of the channel That is Lane
machinsky and Becca beckleman thank you
both so very much for your support from
my work my channel and my mission
and finally this video would not be
possible without the kind support of all
of these lovely people right here these
are my flow patrons over on patreon they
and the people listed down in the
description help to make this video and
all the videos on this channel possible
thank you one and all for your very very
generous support and if you out there
watching are not currently supporter but
you'd like to become one you can do that
by heading on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up there you
can get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards and even better you'll
be helping me out in my mission to bring
POI spinning and flow Arts to the whole
wide world so go check that out please
and thank you if you would like to see
more of my flow videos I will go ahead
and include a link to a playlist of them
down in the description as well as up
here on screen if you are watching on
YouTube also the YouTube algorithm
thinks that you might like this top
video here because reasons so maybe give
that a look as well anyway thanks so
much for watching have yourselves a good
day and I'll see you in the new video on
Friday yeah
peace